but in reality we don't really start  with cosmogin most people I don't teach  cyclic cosmology and my cosmology class  as interested as I am in it to what  extent do people object to the study of  the cyclic Universe what is the  objection that people most present about  the cyclic Universe it doesn't really  matter whether it's energy conversion or  whether it's gravity or  possible with the  output the idea that they grew up with  is might not be the idea or might not be  how nature works so I think that you  know this is the basic attitude right  now in certain parts of the world and  most physicists grow up with this idea  so I think that there's really something  that I take very seriously that people  come with some preconceptions and they  like those preconceptions and then comes  the physics